قدر اوروبا مواجهه روسيا ليس في اوكرانيا
فحسب بل في مناطق توتر مختلفه القاره
العجوز تجتمع في مولدوفا للوقوف في وجه
موسكو الدوله الصغيره الشاهده عن قرب على
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
المجاوره تعيش في خوف مستمر من احتمال
زعزعه استقرارها رساله المجتمعين لموسكو
عنوانها ليست وحدها
مولدوفا وضعها مشابه لاوكرانيا فهي تضم
جيبا انفصاليا الامر يتعلق بترانسنيستريال
المنطقه الانفصاليه المواليه لروسيا التي
يبلغ عدد سكانها 300 الف نسمه شرقي البلاد
وعاصمتها توجد على الشريط الضيق بين نهر
دينيسترو والحدود الاوكرانيه ومعترف بها
دوليا في الوقت الحالي كجزء من مولدوفا
بعد حل الاتحاد السوفيتي تصاعد التوتر بين
مولدوفا واراضي ترانسني الانفصاليه الى
صراع عسكري بدا في مارس من العام
1992 وانتهى بوقف اطلاق النار في يوليو من
العام نفسه ورغم استمرار وقف اطلاق النار
لا يزال الوضع السياسي للاقليم دون حل
فتره
بها لكنها مستقله بحكم الواقع
مولدوفا تتطلع من هذا المنتدى الى
الانضمام للاتحاد الاوروبي ربما كدرع واقي
من اي غزو محتمل من الدب الروسي بلال
البجداني العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات